foreign
[Music]
what is this caught the scammer public
freakout okay
who sent this
uh oh uh this is the fishing one
oh yes thank you oh my God that's right
I had a Twitter video but I guess you
said yeah it's the full video of them
okay do we have a background do we have
a back one on this Terror part I have I
can give you like a tldr version
um so there are these two uh they're
obviously you know there's all these
like fishing championships right
finishing tournaments that happen yeah
um and apparently there were these two
guys who were winning a lot of them okay
um like they won like a boat one one a
boat and like there's all this kind of
stuff so apparently this is them finally
being caught for putting weights in
their fish so that their fish come out
bigger okay so so yeah and apparently
that's I mean I get it that's a big
No-No
right
mm-hmm watch exactly big money yeah so
money and then you also get you might
get sponsorship at one point I mean if
money's involved this is like crime [ __ ]
now right yes it's absolutely fraud they
were literally people keep in mind keep
in mind I've only seen like the the clip
of them pulling the balls out on um on
Twitter but I didn't really
so people were quoted uh being like
these guys are lucky that people didn't
like find them in the parking lot and
like literally kill them
uh it's weights and they'll put smaller
fish in their fish
uh it's weird
the smaller fish is [ __ ] that one's a
[ __ ] old gag because they'll [ __ ]
oh you just ate a fish
I mean with this one they
they stuffed it with uh I believe fish
fillets so that's certainly
yep
yeah they just went to Walmart and
bought some fish fillets and they ate
some fish
wild Alaskan fish fillet
here we see it vacuum sealed in its
natural environment
all right
um all right here we see it's natural
predator the microwave oh no sand
releases Sandra Sandra Lee has spotted
the frozen fish
um
did somebody say fish fillets y'all okay
anyway
hold on you're gonna have to start this
from the beginning the minute you start
it there's someone screaming after all
these [ __ ] years
I don't blame them
I don't know I want to make him mad I
like fishing don't get me wrong it's I I
don't probably I know Frozen you you
really do more often than me but yeah
I don't blame them this is [ __ ] this
is money now like I don't I'm one of
those people like bro even if I don't
like the thing now you're [ __ ] with
people's money you know
you need to be arrested he does
you don't need to call the cops
I don't want anybody to touch these guys
I like this the guy saying that is
wearing jeans and slip-on sandals
that's how you know who's the authority
right you don't get the slip-ons until
you reach level four of bass fishing you
have to wear the slip the the the the
the the toe thong ones till then oh he's
kind of one open here we go and by the
way if you reach level 10 the highest
level of a fisherman Crocs
[Applause]
huge lead weights maybe if maybe the
fish was just [ __ ] by a by a metal
fish and they're having little metal
fish babies
I was just like nah fish eat lead
um I use lead as my bait
oh yeah I mean we all [ __ ] do it I
mean I guess this has been something
they've been known for a while huh yeah
but you're reading more on this story
yeah the dude who runs the tournament is
a police officer
wait a guy the guy who you just heard
saying like I want you guys to leave and
I don't want anybody to touch these guys
I get why he did that because it took
for evidence that makes sense because
he's a cop and he's already said yeah
everything's already been turned over to
law enforcement this is [ __ ] amazing
who says white people don't have culture
this had been somebody cheating in a
basketball tournament it would have
turned into a fist fight a lot faster
huh
I'm just saying
bass fishing still I'm with lead because
I'm gonna win it taper gave me a taper
gave me a little some clarity uh so
taper message me said that tournament
had a 29 000 grand prize the guy stuffed
the fish with lead weights and then put
smaller fish on top of the waste to make
it seem like they had just eaten it was
a walleye tourney wait wait wait wait
sorry we die before weigh in so that's
why they were able to check in the first
place otherwise they would have just
released the fish
so they're so if they didn't do that
that just releasing fish would lead
balls in their stomach pretty much
[Music]
I didn't know how competitive this was
this this super competitive I'm not by
the way I'm not making fun of them I get
it bro everybody has something that
they're good at and and especially if
you're really good at fishing and people
by the way Frozen will tell you this
people think fishing's just like oh fish
you put their line you could have to be
good at fishing you know what I mean you
gotta you have to know what you're doing
and and by the way the other thing is
like be being in these it's expensive
you have to buy all your own equipment
you know dude this ain't this ain't
cheap like yeah 200 bucks I got mine at
TBS it's one of the little pocket ones
it doesn't work
so they were getting the fillets and
they were covering the metal walls with
it
oh so it just looked like the fish was
just like meaty right exactly thick
[ __ ]
that's him
yep
if I'm him I say nothing right now
either that's the right move legally you
know
yeah bro I have something to say
bro why are these fish eating lead balls
we have a real climate change problem
here guys I don't want to be the one to
say it but when I used to fish they
weren't filled with lead balls they're
pulling they're pulling the weights out
of the fish and the guy go the guy just
like nudges the dude next and goes and
we're drinking this water
[Laughter]
what's in US
but you start stabbing people
[ __ ] that's amazing right
or they cut the fish their cake
oh and this guy was a [ __ ] talker that
makes it worse for him he was probably
cocky like I guess I won again
I thank you taper because that helped a
lot I don't really know a lot again I
like fishing for fun
you know but I don't really understand
the tournament aspect of it right I
don't understand it as much easier more
of a Leisure guy yeah so last year
last year these guys also won okay
and they didn't get caught oh I didn't
know
bro bro
this better better Fergie taper just to
hold on taper just told me the last big
fishing cheating scandal ended with the
cheaters boat and truck getting shot up
so these guys don't [ __ ] around Man by
the way
I'm gonna say it and I know it's not
popular rightfully so don't kill people
don't shoot the people but yeah [ __ ]
their boat up I don't give a [ __ ] I I
did I'll put I'll show you after this
one
and just uh
it's like one of those five facts you
need to know about these retards before
they die uh number three shows them in
their brand new boat from last year
that's what I was talking about what
have they got a boat
yeah and it's not a [ __ ] cheap boat
hold on let me take pictures man this
[ __ ] is like
wow I did not know how intense this [ __ ]
was you [ __ ] over a lot of people man
dude this year's all uh walleye Slam
Tournament yeah has over a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars in total prizes
no I got no I mean bro I understand now
like it's it's not even like oh these
Foods they're curious so much about bro
that's [ __ ] money Royce second prize
is fifty five thousand dollars
second prize is 55k
so what you're saying is
dudes [ __ ] up
I should turn down any possible Rumble
deal and become a fisherman because this
sounds way more profitable
honest I think we need to start
refreshing Google on these guys names to
see if they got [ __ ] seriously
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
boat you got thousands of [ __ ]
dollars
all I want is more of this
this is to me more interesting than any
political stuff going on right now
It's [ __ ] amazing oh you're gonna get
more of it because they're going to
court that [ __ ] the dude who runs
this tournament yes [ __ ] pissed
and now the person that got second place
last year has an argument
think about it
yeah they do they they might have
grounds for a civil depending on the
state they might have grounds for a
civil suit yeah I'm trying to see if uh
okay I got a little bit more I gotta
remove this is from just dude from two
hours ago there has been a devastating
scandal in the world of sport okay I
need to I need to skip I need it it's
all of him hold on hold on no no it's
not it's not all of him they're just
playing a clip they they interview the
guy in a second but I just want to see
something real quick there's been a
devastating scandal in the world of
sport at a fishing tournament in
Cleveland on Friday a Duo that had been
declared winners were caught cheating of
course this was fishing so after they
were caught they were released
wait let's hold on a sec was that a joke
that was actually made on national
television with a writing room dude he's
doing Jay Leno bits dude he's doing
pessy bits
Jayla
Jay Leno on his worst day wasn't as bad
as what he's become because Jay Leno
might have been a hack don't get me
wrong and his joke sucked
but at least he never [ __ ] on [ __ ]
any side you know what I mean at least
his jokes as a person as a person and as
a [ __ ] car owner she's one of his
[ __ ] cars
um but I was this is really cool about
him I was watching yeah [ __ ] you up my
course I was watching Louis CK I think
talking about Leno on Rogan did you see
that
um and
it's actually it's actually very here
you know what okay I'll play a little
bit in a second but let's finish this
[Applause]
and that is the perfect segue to our
next guest there Colbert referencing the
investigation underway in an apparent
cheating scandal at a mate was
excuse me competitive angler who was
part of the competition that day he was
there for that moment Steve and his
teammate Brian Ulmer ended up winning
team of the Year honors after those two
allegedly cheating fishermen were
disqualified hell thank you so much
first off congratulations that's a big
honor uh is it you don't even understand
it to be Team of the Year
um but just tell us about this moment as
you witnessed this big honor don't
patronize me man hold from these fish
what was that like
well first off I just want to remind
everyone that CNN is fake news I'm just
coming out here to get my my word across
I hate you uh hey is Anderson Cooper
over there is he jacking some dude off
what about Don Lemon anyway yeah no they
stole [ __ ] I just took this opportunity
to say like Tucker was right and you
guys are a bunch of homos
and you know what else I noticed about
CNN versus Fox News the money that they
have and they spend
every time they have a guest on on Fox
they they usually here's the trick right
whenever you see a guest like on Fox
news or whatever and you're like wow
they're always on like a backdrop so
basically what will happen is
if Tucker's going to interview somebody
and they're in [ __ ] Wellington Ohio
it's a great example like this guy he'll
look up the local Fox they look up the
local Fox affiliate and Wellington Ohio
and go hey can you drive down to the fox
Studio because they'll have like a
remote connect directly to you know
it's that way it looks like in a
professional studio instead CNN's like
yeah just use your webcam Mike and then
you know just do the the and just do the
blur background on Zoom well it was a
crazy weekend we had uh they came up and
uh they had their fish out in the in the
tank and they were getting ready to come
up and they picked up a fish that should
have weighed about four pounds and they
set it on the scale and it said eight
and double they got so cocky that's the
other problem they got because that's
like when you get them that's like a
bully getting a nerd to do his essay and
the nerd goes so a plus and the bully
goes uh make it like a B minus yeah
minus I was reading uh the the walleye
where they were fishing typically way in
between like four or five like a a
monster ass walleye [ __ ] would be
like six pounds so this would be like
there's basically a world record in
weight yes this would be a [ __ ] this
this would be like some [ __ ] where like
if you weighed that [ __ ] fish you
would be calling all your friends
and like with the rest of their five in
and it came up to 35 so everybody was
going nuts as you can see in the video
and it was it was very obvious this time
that uh they weren't going to get away
with that so it's just it's a shame take
it getting away with it I'm just glad
it's too close to the sun it's been a
long time you should have just lived
with it a long time coming you said
you've suspected this in previous
competitions one of the things we've
learned is that you have actually very
well manicured feet for a fisherman one
of the things we've learned is so used
to pretty Larson's at any normal feet
are nice now they're actually polygraphs
in some of the larger competitions
there's polygraphs in fishing oh this is
awesome I think I'm gonna get into this
guys so one of these competitors uh
failed I mean dude like think about it
like a lot of these fishing competitions
do these guys take off a [ __ ] week of
work to do this no no I'm not even
saying this as a joke this is an awesome
like this sounds I know it's hard work
and I know this shit's expensive but
like this is a pretty cool sport
honestly
you've suspected this you and others
we people had good ideas how awesome it
is to be in a sport where you could
drink some Bush lights and still win you
know what I mean that's kind of cool
right and thoughts about it but like
anything you know it's almost
but uh yeah right it's a sport that
literally acquires patience and
relaxation and silence and you know be
funny like if if the Scandal pessy was
yeah look we have to disqualify them
they were drinking Canadian beer and
that's not in the rules it's Molson is
not allowed it's only American Beer so
we're gonna have to disqualify them I'm
so sorry man it's it's okay it's it's
right there no Moosehead yeah no moose
they say that there clearly they go
Coors Bud Miller that's it
[ __ ] moosehead's good though you know
yeah I know if you're a cheater at
fishing
yeah some [ __ ] when you fail one and
pass one and and there's different
things and they block I'm so sick of
these fishermen moosen you know it's a
problem
using performance enhancing drugs eh
everybody the guy's getting the guy
drinking the Canadian beers getting let
out at Cuffs in cuffs and there's this
like clearly Japanese man with like a
fake mustache and mullet on just kicking
a box of Sapporo underneath his truck
she very good Sushi five six seven eight
pounds every time and just you know some
shady stuff going on so
um they've been investigated they've
done the polygraphs you know Jason
Fisher's done a great job trying to
do polygraphs and testing and asking
questions and doing everything he can do
uh obedient to ya says no it requires a
lot of effort actually
yeah I know but I could do a lot of
things that require efforts drinking or
high buddy
do you think I go to the gym not high
are you [ __ ] insane
imagine being there sober you to keep it
legit but
um
they got they got it this time so
you know I wonder in this case we're
talking about weights of almost eight
pounds and it seems like maybe if they'd
gone for Less they would have gotten
away with it wow did you come up with
that all by yourself by using common
logic now she actually read it she
actually saw it in this uh in this
cartoon about this uh dog that uh talks
and it goes around in this van with
these with the stinky hippie and like
these and and these this clearly gay men
and lesbian and oh hot Ginger you're
clearly talking of the A-Team right yes
let's sandbag you
um
Mr T is that hot Ginger
um